first thing to notice about JPEG is it's
not actually a file format although
everyone talks about JPEG files JPEG is
actually a compression method much like
the codec you would use in a video and
we actually use the JPEG file and change
format or Japheth as the actual wrapper
that holds that compressed data so what
happened was though your joint
photographic experts group which is what
JPEG stands for came along and they
created this incredibly complex
specification of how you should compress
image data very long lots of different
options and what that means is basically
in practice
you couldn't possibly hope to implement
all the different options progressive
jpg sequential JPEG files different
color spaces and so no one did someone
came along and said how about this
Japheth format and everyone's actually
that's much easier and now everyone just
uses that and more recently the exif
format which has been sort of championed
by the photographic industry and camera
makers has kind of joined with Japheth
and so you all ever have exif files or
Japheth files or both in the same file
they still have the doc J they will have
dot JPEG and so really when we're
talking about a JPEG file we're actually
talking about a Japheth file most of the
time but we just don't make that
distinction JPEG compression works in a
very clever way so first of all it
depends on the fact that we don't see
color quite as well as we do greyscale
which is something we touched upon in
our video on the biofilter who greens
for every blue and red and that's
because our eyes are more sensitive to
green than they are to blue and red it
also deals with the fact that we don't
see high frequency changes in image
intensity very well either so we can get
rid of some of our high frequency
information so bits of image would
change intensity very very quickly we
can kind of sort of blur out and those
things will go away we won't really see
a difference certainly if we're not
zooming right in looking at individual
pixels so to start with we'll talk just
about the color aspects of JPEG I have
an input image here what we want to do
is try and shrink it down as small as
possible for storage and then be able to
extract as much as possible on the way
out so what we first do is we we change
the color space we transform it into the
ycbcr color space which is what we spoke
about in our little video on color
spaces what we're trying to do with
ycbcr is separate
luminosity of an image so the intensity
of each pixel from the actual color
after we've converted to ycbcr we down
sample and essentially reduce the amount
of color in our image and that lets us
save quite a lot of space without
actually seeing any difference in the
image quality we then apply discrete
cosine transform which is a fairly
complicated mathematical technique which
hopefully I can explain in a slightly
slightly easy-to-understand way and then
we quantize it which is the actual lossy
part of the JPEG compression then we
encode it and that's our file
what is lossy me some file formats that
we encounter like BMP and PNG are
losslessly compressed so there we
essentially it's equivalent to putting
them in a zip file you might use LZ
compression or something something more
complicated but generally speaking you
take the image data you compress it in
such a way that when you uncompress it
the other side is exactly the same I
believe that professor Brailsford did a
video on LZ compression in JPEG the
compression is almost always lossy you
aren't guaranteed the same image at when
you output it as you did as you put in
however it will be very very close most
of the time and the advantage of loss
lossy compression is you get huge amount
more compression for your money JPEG
allowed you to do any basically any
color space you wanted you could use RGB
you could use ycbcr or you could use CIE
lab and all these different ones and
because of the fact that it's totally
impractical to program up every single
possible color space in your own JPEG
encoder or decoder most people didn't
most people just followed the japheth
standard which is just ycbcr very
occasionally RGB ok so we're going to
assume for the rest of this video that
we're talking about japheth which is
essentially a small subset of a JPEG
standard so we take our image which is
an RGB and we convert it into Y CB CR
and what that does is separate out the
luminance and the chrominance components
and as we talked about in our video
luminance represents essentially the
brightness of the image and it's a
grayscale component and the CB and CR
represent the blueness and the redness
of our image but both of these values
fall after conversion in
japheth Stan had fall into the range of
nought to 255 so V the amount of data
VAT ycbcr holds is exactly the same as
the noir to 255 RGB one of the nice
things about y cbcr is that human eye
doesn't really see Cronin's very well
it's certainly a much lower resolution
and we see changes in intensity so just
like with TV encoding what we can do is
we can massively downsample the amount
of CB and CR that we see in the image
and most humans initial zoom right in on
the pixels won't see any difference at
all so to use a demonstration this is a
flower picture that I took and this
picture on the right has had the
chromeless components down sampled by a
factor of 10 in both directions so
hundred overall there's a hundred times
less color in this picture of enemies in
this one and to my eye they look almost
exactly the same and that's because my
eye only sees the grayscale and a little
bit of color if you zoom right in on
these pixels you can see right on the
edge of some of these petals here you
can see slight discrepancies where the
color and the gray don't match up but at
a normal level of zoom the sort of level
of zoom of your computer monitor or a
screen you're looking at or a photograph
you're never going to see the difference
and we've managed to save a huge amount
of space by getting rid of a huge amount
of color information once we transform
into ycbcr we have to decide how much
downsampling we think we can get away
with in general it's very common to down
sample the color by a factor of two in
both directions so essentially you have
four times less color for every four Y
pixels you only have one cbcr pixel okay
you might also down sample by a factor
of two only in the vertical direction
and keep the horizontal depending on how
much space you want to save in general
down sampling by that much you won't see
much of a change in the image so you can
get away of quite a lot so down sampling
is sometimes tied to the quality of a
JPEG that you output so in some software
you will say I want it a quality of 85
and it will decide how much down
something that is and how much of a
compression that it does later on in the
stages in general most software will use
a down sampling of two in both so four
times less color but you might find if
you choose the highest quality in a
software such as Photoshop it won't down
sampler tool and it
have the same resolution of color to
greyscale so once we've taken RGB image
we've converted it into y cbcr and we've
done whatever down sampling we think is
necessary or what we can get away with
that's when we pass this information
onto a DCT but discrete cosine transform
which is right at the core of how JPEG
compression works but that's whenever
video there's a low frequency change
from this black table to a brightness
over my jumper to darktable again and as
much higher frequency changes on my
jumper where we go up and down within
sort of the woolen knit and it's the
same kind of principle